in the MCU everyone's favorite foul
miles trigger happy rodent has always
been known as Rocket but where did he
get his name and what species is he
really warning spoilers ahead that's the
last movie in James Gunn's Trilogy of
sci-fi epics the Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 sends off its team of Misfits in
high fashion rather than saving the
universe this time around the gang is on
a mission to save Rocket's life but to
do so they'll have to scour their
friends past and find a way to bypass a
kill switch activated inside of him as
the story unfolds the audience has
treated the flashbacks of Rocket's
origin and then we learn how he was
experimented on by the high evolutionary
to become the hyper-intelligence jaded
rodent we all know and love audiences
get to see rocket go from a baby raccoon
to creature learning the basics of
science all the way to innovating on the
high evolutionaries processes and
naturally there's a point where the
audience learns where rocket got his
namesake as the high evolutionary
teachers rocket the little mammal sees a
ship takeoff and correctly identifies it
as a rocket later when rocket and his
cohorts are in their cages they discuss
naming themselves this is a small active
Rebellion against a high evolutionary
and their designations he's given them
Rocket's friends name themselves Lila
thieves and floor when his Rockets turn
he recalls how he has always dreamed of
going into the sky and remembers a ship
Escaping The Power of gravity in that
fateful moment he gives himself his true
name given his tragic upbringing it's no
surprise that rocket is deeply insecure
about his body and his place in the
world he has a long history of getting
offended when people refer to him as an
animal he's being called everything from
a rabbit to a badger Peter Quill calls
him a raccoon an animal rocket has never
heard of what's a raccoon what's a
raccoon it's what you are stupid ain't
no thing like me except me each time
he's compared to an animal rocket
explodes in Anger he's always viewed
himself as one of a kind so being
compared to a rodent or a critter is
perhaps the greatest insult to him
however Rocket's sense of self is
challenged when he finds a lab on the
high evolutionary ship housing other
animals including a cage of baby
raccoons as Rocket opens the cage and
the babies quickly flock to him he sees
a label and this at that moment the
rocket learns what he's been all along a
raccoon in the comics rocket has always
been Rocket Raccoon but explaining his
species and the movies has been on the
back burner in the MCU where he's only
been referred to as rocket that changes
during his final confrontation with the
high evolutionary as Rocket lets him
know once and for all that he's not just
an experiment he's Rocket Raccoon it's a
celebratory moment where rocket fully
Embraces who he is he spent a lifetime
running away from his past and the
painful memories that lurk there but
with one defiant statement he makes it
clear that the high evolutionary no
longer controls him Rockets calling the
shots from now on and he has his family
to back him up with their help rocket
takes on the high evolutionary One Last
Time rocket is indeed a raccoon and it's
nothing for him to be ashamed of after
all the trauma and abuse he's endured
he's finally come to accept where he's
from this newfound sense of place an
identity allows him to move on as the
new captain of the Guardians of the
Galaxy
[Music]
foreign